i would like to
welcome our next presenter
to the session
um
mcgregor
is pronounced melisha
thank you melisha yeah um she's her talk
is on using reproducible experiments to
create better machine learning models
malicious senior software engineer she's
an international tech speaker and mad
scientist that works with hardware and
software
she tries to make anything with
javascript first
and in her free time she enjoys
learning how to ride a unicycle and
playing with her dog
so
with that welcome to pi data global and
i'll uh
turn the session over to you thanks
alicia all right it sounds good
let me
perform the magical feat of sharing my
screen
hey everybody my name is melisha and i'm
a developer advocate at
iterative.ai and i mostly work on our
open source tool dvc
which helps you make
reproducible experiments
but if you have any questions
and you want to ask them
just like to me directly you can reach
out on the slack or you can reach out to
me personally on twitter at
flippedcoding
or if you want to get into like some
technical details behind the open source
stuff you can reach out to the whole
team on twitter at dvc.org
but with that being said today i want to
talk to you about using reproducible
experiments to make better models
so
let's just jump right in
some common issues that come up whenever
you're making machine learning models
does it matter what
the particular problem is it doesn't
matter what
solution you go with it's just some
things that pop up
so one of those issues starts with our
original search for the best combination
of hyper parameters whatever algorithm
or algorithms we need to use in our data
set so it's basically like us
having a map and we put all of these
little different points and we're hoping
that wherever they cross we find our
treasure which is our really good model
that we can get to production right
so we're trying to find this combination
of
all of these
different things like hyper parameters
are so very different from algorithms
which are
completely different from data sets and
we have to find what works the best
so something that happens is that you
start trying all of these different
things maybe you start with
a neural network and then you see that's
not quite the right approach so
you shift radically to some linear
regression model or whatever it is but
every time you make a change you have to
keep track of all of those changes and
what happens over time
is that
it's just really hard to follow
everything because you have these
different experiments where you've
been testing out models and
it gets to the point where you're like
well
this model looks really good so it has
this great accuracy that's way higher
than anything we ever hoped for the loss
is really
small and it doesn't take that long to
trade
so you have this great model and then
somebody asked you well what did you do
to get this model and you're just kind
of like
um
i think this is the one that i use this
random
forest classifier on
or maybe this is the one where i had the
learning rate set to 0.5
or maybe
i was using that data set that we got a
month ago
but then you know the business and
requirements changed and we got this
updated when a couple of weeks ago so
you have to keep up with all of those
changes and it's
interesting the different tools that
teams use for this so
some people use spreadsheets where they
have links to their
git commits
and links to their data set which is
some kind of zip file or google drive
some people try to
take all of their experiments and put
them in individual zip files where they
have the data the code and the hyper
parameters or whatever other configs
but
the thing is over time when you're
doing all of these little changes
it's just hard to remember which one was
the good one
which one
did you learn something from
it gets really messy really fast
so
how do we actually fix that problem
right
and the way that we do that
is by making our experiments
reproducible and to make an experiment
reproducible you have to keep track of
all of those little bitty changes you
make when you're running experiments
while you're trying to figure out what
the best model is for your problem
so let's say
you decide you want to update the hyper
parameters that's an experiment
and then let's say you want to update
your data set that's a separate
experiment so what we really need to do
is have a way to
bundle all of these changes for us and
be able to go back
to any previous experiment because maybe
you've been running experiments on your
model for
two weeks
and you figure out oh i remember that
one thing from last week that told me my
accuracy is was like 85 percent
and then you're stuck with this problem
of like
how do i get back to that model but when
you have something tracking all of those
changes for you you don't have to worry
about the reproducibility part because
every experiment is tracked
so i'm going to set this up with just a
little
a little background on hyper parameter
tuning because if you've done any type
of machine learning work you've probably
run into some hyper parameter tuning at
some point
so usually
well just in case you have it i do want
to let you know what that is
and hyperparameters first off are the
parameters that define your model so
these are the things like
if you have a neural net it might be the
number of layers in that net or if you
have a random forest classifier it might
be the
max depth for that algorithm so
these are the kind of parameters we're
looking at things like your learning
rate
maybe a momentum somewhere
maybe some kind of men split but
they're the
parameters that define your model so you
can't get them from training you can't
get them from
well really anywhere it's a lot of
guesswork which is why you end up
running a lot of different experiments
to figure out what is the best set of
hyper parameters for your model
and a couple of common methods that are
used to do this are grid search and
random search
so grid search
is a very exhaustive search and let's
say for example you have three hyper
parameters you have a
learning rate a momentum and
i don't know
let's go with a max depth so you have
these three hyper parameter values
and you've assigned each of them 10
values each
because you think
somewhere in this range of numbers
is your optimum
so
with a grid search
you will go through every possible
combination of those hyper parameters
if there's an optimum to be found grid
search is definitely going to find it
but on the other side we have random
search so even though grid search will
eventually find that optimum
it takes a lot of time a lot of
resources and a lot of experiments
but with random search
you still have those three same hyper
parameters they still have those same 10
values a piece
except instead of
going through each possible combination
random search just kind of hops around
and
mixes things together in
maybe a specific way if you're using
something like a bayesian or gaussian
thing but
most of the time it's just hopping
around checking different combinations
of values
and what happens is usually random
search finds a better optimum than grid
search in a similar amount of time just
because random search
tests a wider range of values for you
so how does this all actually fit into
what i'm talking about with
reproducibility and tracking experiments
it's where dvc comes in because it's a
tool that does all of that for you
but dvc is something that is
open source so you can look at the code
for yourself and see what's happening
it works on top of git
i know a lot of the other tools out
there like
maybe ml flow or tensorboard they're
great like don't get me wrong if you
have a use case form you should
definitely use those but something that
dvc does differently is it works on top
of git so it has a way
to connect your code and your data so
you get the code versioning through git
and you get data versioning through dvc
and all of that is combined in this nice
little package that is completely
unopinionated so you don't have to
import anything into your code there's
no libraries for you to use you don't
have to call an api to track things
you just run this in your terminal
and it handles all of the experiment
management for you so
with dvc you can have
hundreds thousands of experiments and
you don't have to worry about tracking
anything
dvc just kind of works in the background
as you're doing these different like
maybe you're training your model to see
what the metrics are around it dvc
tracks all of that so it gets every
little code change you make
it keeps track of all of those different
combinations of hyper parameter values
which if you've done hyperparam tuning
without a tool
it gets very tedious trying to keep up
with those little changes because it's
like
well my learning rate was 0.5 here
that didn't work out so let's see what
happens when it's 0.1 and then you have
to get the data set and zip it up you
have to get the code and zip it you have
to get the hyper params and zip it and
then somehow you're supposed to be able
to look at the metrics for this later on
yeah
it gets messy really fast so that's why
we use tools to make those things easy
for us so that we can focus on the
machine learning part
so with dvc if you run an experiment
you'll just be using this little command
at the top the dvc exp run
and
what it does it takes your code your
data and any configs like your hyper
params bundles it together
and
then you have your reproducible little
packet that lets you go back to any
experiment because
it has a record of the exact
environment that you ran this experiment
in which if you've ever had to deploy a
model to a different environment you
know how much of a difference that can
make when you don't have the exact same
conditions
so dvc is just one of those tools that
lets you pack all of this together
without you having to really think about
it you set it up in your project you
connect it to your get repo you connect
it to any
like remote areas maybe you have your
data on aws maybe you have it hosted in
azure
and you connect all of these things to
dvc kind of like you see in this picture
and it just tracks it for you
so
what's happening
after you run an experiment is exactly
this
it takes your data whatever the data set
is for that experiment it tracks that
it tracks your hyperparams of course and
it tracks your code so
not only is it keeping track of all of
this it's also
making it really easy to access the
metrics for each experiment so that
you can get a really quick view of what
what you might want to go back to what
direction you might want to take your
experiments next
it just bundles everything up really
neatly for you
so this is an example of
us running an experiment with dvc
and as you can see
we have a couple of hyperparams here on
the right with our train.nest
in our min split those are just two
hyper params that we're tuning for this
little example
and then we have our metrics that we're
following so we have this average
precision and this rock auc value
but
this is what the table looks like with
just
one experiment by the time we finish
this this table is going to be so big
that it won't fit on the page
but
let's go through a normal flow of
hyperparameter tuning
so you decide
that you want to
tune your hyperparams to
you know get better performance out of
your model maybe get that last five
percent of accuracy that you need or
whatever metric it is you're trying to
get
so you get your hyper parameters and you
have the values for each of them so you
want to set up a queue of experiments
because again
when you have to run through all of
those changes just
sitting in front of a computer
waiting for an experiment to run
and then you literally increment a
number by one or by some fraction
it gets
it gets to be a lot so with something
like dvc
we give it
all of the values for all of the hyper
parameters
and it sets up a queue of experiments
for us
so before you even get to the stage
where you run one this is what the table
looks like
and what this allows you to do
is let's say you're working on a team
with other machine learning engineers
and you're all running these same kind
of experiments
so before you run your queued up
experiments you might want to check with
them and be like hey
did y'all already try this set of hyper
parameter values
is this a direction that we should go in
and they can look and see this
combination right here before you run
anything and be like well
we haven't used these values yet so it'd
probably be worthwhile to
run those experiments
and what you would do when you're ready
to run them
is just you use this command this dvc
exp run run all and that runs every
experiment in your queue
no matter how many you have in that
queue it will execute all of them
so
that's something to keep in mind if
you're thinking about offloading some of
this training to
some kind of cloud environment
you don't have to sit there and just
watch them run you can come back and
look at them later and something else
that dvc does if you wanted to run these
experiments in parallel so that maybe
you know you speed up
your time for tuning or you have some
kind of resource constraint you can do
that
so dvc gives you a lot of flexibility
with running multiple experiments
but after you've run everything
then you probably want to look at the
results right so we show those results
in the table
and you can see now
we have all of these different
hyperparameter combinations and we have
all of these metrics associated with
them
so
each experiment as you can see over here
on the left has an id associated with it
these ids are how we are able to
throw in that reproducibility
if at any point you decide that one of
these experiments looks like it's
something you should dig into
you can just
take this
take the id of that experiment apply it
to your workspace and it will load in
all of your code hyperparams and data to
give you the exact results that you see
in this table
so
we're looking at this table after we've
run all of these experiments and you see
we have a pretty
pretty wide range of average precisions
all the way from 46
up to 50 percent
so maybe you decide that you need
another eye to look at things because
maybe something just feels a little
weird to you about this
so you decide you want to make up a plot
to show everybody on your team because
that's what we do right we take
experiments and we compare them
so you run that dvc plots diff command
with whatever experiment ids you want to
compare
and you get these plots
just like this
so
here you can see
you know the precision versus the recall
tpr versus the fpr
and all of these metrics are actually
coming straight from your training
script so it's not some magic that dvc
is doing
it's just referencing the json files
that you produce from your experiments
so that is all that's happening here
that's all that shows in the table as
well
so
you take these plots to your colleagues
and y'all sit around and talk about them
and decide you know what we need to run
more experiments
so you set up a queue of experiments
again and this time maybe you decide
well i'll have time to finish out the
rest of this great search
let's just
random
search some things
so we get these definitely random values
over here for our hyperparameters
again we queue them up just so that we
can check with our associates to see has
anybody seen
any values in this range of
hyperparameters
if not
of course we're just going to go ahead
and execute them so we'll run all of our
experiments and then we'll look at the
table again
and now you see
these values are looking really really
similar
so maybe there's something about this
90 to 125
range for the nest
maybe there's something to this
i don't know between 300 and 500 for the
men split
but
you're able to look at these metrics
right here you don't have to go into
some other tool this is just a table
that's in your terminal
like
that's it it's just a cli tool that you
use and it shows you all of this
information without you having to sign
up for anything you don't have to log in
anywhere
you don't have to make ap guide calls to
anything
it's just here
and you see your metrics really easily
you see your hyper params associated
with them really easily
and you decide you want to run more
experiments because those values are all
too close together so we set up our
queue again
and we have a different set of hyper
parameter values here
and we're just going to go ahead and do
our regular thing we'll run them and
we'll look at our table
and
you know it looks like something did a
little bit better
so maybe this is the direction we need
to go with our experiments but before we
do that
we'll probably consult with everybody on
the team one more time so we'll take
them this plot that has
an experiment from one of our previous
runs and it has an experiment from today
so we look at these and we definitely
see there's
a decent difference between them
so you'll talk with your team
figure out which direction you want to
go
and then just continue running these
experiments
so by the time you're finished you get
some table that looks a lot like this
and imagine back in the beginning before
we used a tool like this
trying to keep track of all of this so
so neatly
so
each of these experiments
has
data associated with it it has code
changes associated with them it has all
of these different hyper parameter
combinations associated with them
and
can you imagine having to keep track of
all of this just with
a spreadsheet and some zip files
that
i've i've had to do that before and it's
not fun and it's not easy and when you
do want to go back you have to hope
nobody else has messed up a row on the
spreadsheet
so having a table like this to look
through and having a tool that lets you
easily go back and forward through your
experiments as you try to figure out
which direction you actually want to go
before this model hits production
and not only before it hits production
but
what exactly do you deploy to pride now
you know the exact things that you have
to deploy to production to get the
results that you expect
so
hopefully this table like
took away some of that anxiety from
trying to do all of these experiments
and track them
just by yourself or even if you have a
team that you work with it's going to be
really really hard to keep track of all
of those experiments between everybody
and be able to share them compare them
this makes it easy to do
all of that
but i do want to just wrap up with a few
key takeaways to leave some question
some time for questions
but the first thing
adding reproducibility is so important
because you don't want to get to that
point where you do have this incredible
model and you showed everybody on your
team how well it performs
and then
everybody's in agreement that yes this
is the one that should definitely go to
pride and you have no idea what exactly
to deploy to pride so then you have to
start digging through all of these
changes going through git commits zip
files
and it gets messy really fast and it
takes a lot of time to just try to sort
through everything
but when you have reproducibility from
the beginning is just as simple as
referencing an id
and you get all of your changes back
and of course dvc helps you do this
because it's keeping track of everything
in the background
you don't have to worry about what your
hyper params are at the moment all you
have to do is run your experiments and
then you can go and look at the metrics
and how well they performed
and the last thing i really really want
to emphasize of course i was talking
about dvc today and of course i would
love it if you checked out bbc
but i totally understand that there are
a bunch of other tools out there that
are targeted at mlaps so
kind of my challenge to you for today is
just go check out some of those tools
maybe hopefully dvc is the one that you
really like but if it's not there's
stuff like mlflow intensive board and a
bunch of other products so just try them
out because these tools are here to make
your life easier you don't have to you
don't have to implement this thing you
don't have to write the code for it just
check out the tools see what works best
for your processes
and go with it because even though it
might be a pain you can always change
later
but
with that being said i want to wrap up
and leave some time for questions and
again you can ask me questions
now you can ask them on slack you can
ask me on twitter at flippedcoding
or if you really just want to dive into
dvc and you want some help getting
things set up or debugging
feel free to join our discord channel
a lot of people come in there just to
get help getting unstuck on their
projects and we have the time
so are there any questions
malaysia it's jennifer i'm i'm wondering
if you have uh
you know anything you'd like to see um
added to dvc that would be helpful
in
you know where do you see the expansion
there um
i think
honestly a lot of stuff that we have on
the road map are things that i've been
kind of asking for it's like
dvc is such a powerful tool that it'd be
nice to have
just commands that make it easier to get
started with experiments and that's on
the roadmap so
instead of just
like having to set up everything you can
just set up the part that does
experiments so i'm pretty excited about
that coming out soon that's great um
well that's something
to to uh
follow for audition maybe next year on
your wish list
um
thanks for thanks for joining us and uh
and your discussion and for being part
of pi data global 2021 and
thanks everyone here for
for joining